ils sont l'oeil et la plume de loire
valley magazine catherine tara l'on met
en forme les mots marc broussard capture
l'instant au travers de son objectif là
quand je regarde cette façade avec tout
cet art d'oise
je compare sur la gauche à tout mais
ardoise qui sont célèbres de françois
1er est tout moi je me dis que c'est on
aime c'est une belle réussite quoi
penser de réunir ces bâtiments 7 n'est
pas de facile mais j'aime bien le
contraste entre le noir des ardoises
tous les deux sont tombés sous le charme
du val de loire du puy il le sillonnent
pour mettre en valeur tout ce que le
lieu recèle en termes de qualité de vie
qu'il s'agisse de culture de tourisme de
gastronomie d'architecturé parmi bien
d'autres choses on a eu envie de faire
loire valley magazine parce qu on se
rendait compte depuis des années qu'on
possède la presse nationale et
internationale que la loire y avait des
trésors partout tout le monde le savait
tout le sait mais j'avais envie de les
tirer et qu'on les met en scène d'une
manière beaucoup plus moderne et qu'on
la porte
hors de ses frontières c'est ça l'idée
loire valley magazine leur reportage du
jour les conduit au relais de chambord
au pied du château durant deux ans de
travaux l'établissement a été
entièrement retravaillée extérieure
comme intérieure par des architectes et
designers de renom le relais vient de
rouvrir à la clientèle et aux
observateurs attentifs on t'a mise en
garde est là l'ancienne cheminée ça
c'est un travail de designer là
guillaume salle bureau d assemblage de
style entre renaissance et 21e siècle
retrouvé un peu partout dans
l'établissement dans les chambres bien
sûr mais jusqu'au bout au tiff de la
moquette emprunté à l' architecture du
château voisin
la bibliothèque de la réception de
l'hôtel assure le coup de coeur de la
visite
le meuble est saisissant sa décoration
aussi alliant livres anciens et vaste
contemporain un régal pour le
photographe et des photos réalisées en
osmose avec le texte de l'article ne
sait pas trop qui a commencé là
l'histoire mais on sait que le tout doit
être cohérent et ça c'est important
si vous avez des photographies qui ne
raconte pas grand chose et un texte
merveilleux ça va être bancal si vous
avez la verse
le reportage sur le relais de chambord
apparaîtra bientôt en ligne sur le site
de loire valley magazine et nouveautés
il figurera également dans le recueil de
reportages qui sera édité en version
papier dans le courant du mois de mai